>> Greg: THAT WAS A CLOSE ONE.
HAPPY FRIDAY.
HAPPY JULY 4TH WEEKEND.
FROM YOUR FAVORITE LITTLE
FIRECRACKER, ME.
JUST REMEMBER TO BE CAREFUL OUT
THERE.
I'D HATE TO SEE YOU LOSE A
FINGER, LIKE MY CHILDHOOD FRIEND
WE HAD TO CALL MITTENS.
YEAH.
IN CASE YOU SCOFF AT THE IDEA
THAT THE MEDIA WORKS FROM THE
SAME SCRIPT, THE SAME PLAYBOOK,
SAME OXYGEN DEPRIVED BRAIN, YOU
NEED TO SEE THURSDAY'S
"L.A. TIMES" PIECE ON HOW
LATE-NIGHT SELECTED COMEDIANS
COVERED THE HEARINGS.
THE SAME UNISON RESPONSE.
OR SHOULD I SAY UNISOM.
SINCE THEY WERE DULL ENOUGH TO
PUT A METHOD INTO A COMA.
>> WE ARE COMING TO JUST HOURS
AFTER THE JANUARY 6, AND HE
SHOCKED WITH A HEARING I CAN
ONLY BE DESCRIBED AS CUCKOO.
AH-OOG-AH.
>> I WAS SHOCKED THAT TRUMP
THREW ANY OF HIS FOOD AWAY.
>> THIS GUY HAS TAKEN MORE
SELFIES WITH FOOD THEN HE HAS
WITH SOME OF HIS KIDS.
>> WHO THE HELL ELECT HIM OUT OF
HIS CAR SEAT.
HE PROBABLY FINISHED HIS BIG MAC
FIRST.
>> WHO HAD CATCH UP AT LUNCH?
>> Greg: THOSE SHOWS SHOULD
COME WITH A WARNING, DO NOT
OPERATE HEAVY MACHINERY
AFTERWARD.
OR EXPECT AMUSEMENT WHILE
VIEWING.
THEY AREN'T EVEN TRYING TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX.
MAYBE BECAUSE IT'S MALAKOFF AND
WHERE, AND TO DIE.
THEY THINK COMMONLY ISN'T THEIR
JOB AND IF YOU WATCH A FEW
MINUTES, YOU'LL AGREE IT'S NOT N
THEIR HOBBY.
INSTEAD THEIR JOB IS TO SPOUT
ACCEPTABLE LIBERAL ELITIST
ASSUMPTIONS TO BE SAFE.
MEANWHILE THEIR AUDIENCE FEELS
LIKE THEY ARE IN A TV ROOM AT
GITMO AND PETE HEGSETH HAS BEEN
HOLDING THE REMOTE.
WHICH EXPLAINS WHY THEIR
AUDIENCE AND SHRINKING LIKE IT'S
GOT A SPEEDO FOR LOVE ICE CUBE'S
MEANWHILE, OUR RATINGS ARE SICK
IN A GOOD WAY.
>> [CHEERING]
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THE TEAMS SAY.
WE ARE SICK.
IN A GOOD WAY.
NOT IN A "HEY, WHAT ARE THESE
SORES AND WHY DO I WANT TO EAT
BANANAS AND FLING MY FECES."
SHADOW TO MONKEYPOX.
IT IS LIKE WE ARE DOING
A SMASH-AND-GRAB AND TAKING ONLY
THE GOOD STUFF WHICH LEADS ME
BACK TO THE "L.A. TIMES."
THEY COVERED WHAT THE LATE
NIGHTERS SET ABOUT JANUARY 6 BUT
MYSTERIOUSLY LEFT OFF ONE SHOW.
WHAT SHOW COULD THAT BE?
DO YOU THINK IT'S THE ONE THAT
A, ISN'T.
TING THE OTHER SHOWS?
B, BEATING THE CRAP OUT OF THEM
IN LESS THAN A YEAR OF BEING ON
AIR, AND C, WHOSE HOST IS HOTTER
THAN THE HANDLE OF A CAST-IRON
SKILLET.
YOU ARE NOT LETTING ME FINISH.
I WANT TO REREAD THAT ONE.
AND C, WHOSE HOST IS HOTTER THAN
THE HANDLE OF A CAST-IRON
SKILLET LEFT IN THE OVEN FOR
THREE HOURS.
THANKS FOR WRITING THAT, KAT.
>> Kat: [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: THAT IS THIS SHOW.
WHY WOULD THE "L.A. TIMES" LEAVE
US OUT OF THEIR RECAP?
WHAT COULD THE REASONING BE?
THERE IS NONE.
WHEN THE LEADING LATE-NIGHT SHOW
IS BUCKING THE CONFORMITY OF
THOSE OTHER SHOWS, YOU'D THINK
THAT WOULD BE A STORY PERHAPS
EVEN A BIG ONE FOR THE WRITER
WHOSE BEAT IS LATE-NIGHT TV.
BUT NO, THEY IGNORE THE SHOW
LIKE IT WAS ME TRYING TO GET A
LAP DANCE AT APPLEBEE'S.
I GET CONFUSED.
IT'S ALL THOSE BRIGHT LIGHTS.
AGAIN, THE QUESTION IS WHY.
IT IS LIKELY JANUARY 6TH
HEARINGS.
IF YOU DON'T SHOW THE OTHER SIDE
OF ANYTHING, IT HELPS YOU THINK
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOUR CAR IS
MAKING A STRANGE NOISE SO YOU
TURN UP THE RADIO AND SUDDENLY
THE NOISE IS GONE.
IT'S LIKE COVERING YOUR EYES AND
STICKING YOUR FINGERS IN YOUR
EARS AND SINGING LA, LA, LA, LA.
WHICH IS HOW DOCTORS SAY IS THE
SAFEST WAY TO GET THROUGH
"FOX & FRIENDS."
WITH FEW EXCEPTIONS, THE
MAINSTREAM PRESS HAS BENT OVER
BACKWARDS TO IGNORE OUR SUCCESS,
SINCE IGNORING IT MEANS WE DON'T
EXIST.
THERE COULD BE NO VIABLE
ALTERNATIVES.
IF THEIR MINDS WERE ANYMORE
CLOSE, THEY WOULD BE A
POST OFFICE ON JULY 4TH.
SO WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT THEIR
BELIEFS OR THEIR EGOS?
MAYBE THEY KNOW THAT NEITHER CAN
STAND UP TO A CHALLENGE.
IT'S THE SAME THING THAT
HAPPENED WHEN FOX NEWS LAUNCHED
25 YEARS AGO.
THEY LAUGHED.
THEY MOCKED.
YOU SEE SAW HOW THAT TURNED OUT.
STOPPING THEM LIKE GRAPES UNDER
THE FEET OF AN ITALIAN
WINEMAKER.
I GET ASKED THIS QUESTION A LOT
FROM COLLEGE KIDS.
WHERE AND WHY AND WHY AM I TIED
UP?
BUT ALSO HOW DO I RESPOND TO
PEOPLE WHO OUTNUMBER ME ON
CAMPUS AND TRASH ME FOR MY
BELIEFS?
I ALWAYS SAY STAB THEM IN THE
FACE.
WITH TRUTH.
AND A KNIFE.
MADE OF HONESTY.
WHEN PEOPLE GIVE YOU BELIEF FOR
BEING DIFFERENT, JUST SAY, DO
YOU EVER WONDER WHY YOU CHOOSE
THE HARDER PATH?
WHY WOULD I MAKE IT HARD ON
MYSELF?
I COULD JUST DO YOU.
ARE YOU CURIOUS AS TO WHY I
WOULD MAKE MYSELF LESS POPULAR
THAN A CLASS CALLED INTRO TO
CHLAMYDIA.
DO YOU EVER WONDER WHY WE ARE
DOING YOU?
IT'S BECAUSE WE ARE DUMB OR
CRAZY?
OR MAYBE SOMETHING I KNOW
SOMETHING YOU DON'T.
THE ANSWER ISN'T AS IMPORTANT AS
THEM HEARING THAT QUESTION.
IT'S LIKE WHEN I ASK MY WIFE WHY
HER TENNIS PRO IS LIVING WITH
US.
SURE, I COULD DO THEIR LIBERAL
LATE-NIGHT SHTICK.
PANDERING IS THE EASIEST FORM OF
COMEDY.
I WISH SOMEONE COULD EXPLAIN
THAT TO THE WRITERS AT "SNL."
THEY ARE STILL DOING TRUMP IS AN
EVIL CHEETO JOKES WHILE SAYING
NOTHING OF A PRESIDENT WHO
FLOPPED OFF A BIKE LIKE HE WAS
ROUNDING A TURN IN THE
TOUR de FRANCE.
PEOPLE IN THIS INDUSTRY DON'T
LIKE US, MANY MYSELF, KAT,
TYRUS.
I AM GUESSING TYRUS CATCHES A
LITTLE BLESSED THAT THE REST OF
US.
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT GIVING
CRAP TO A GUY WHO IS NOT ONLY
SMARTER THAN YOU BUT COULD FOLD
YOU INTO HIS WALLET.
BUT I LOST FRIENDS THE MORE
SUCCESSFUL THE SHOW BECAME.
BEFORE I WAS JUST HARMLESS.
THEY COULD PAT ME ON THE HEAD
AND SAY HE JUST DOESN'T KNOW ANY
BETTER.
THEN WHEN THE WINNING BEGAN,
SUDDENLY THEY DON'T WANT YOU
AROUND ANYMORE.
THEY WILL MARGINALIZE YOUR
IDEAS.
SAY YOU USED TO BE FUNNY BUT NOT
ANYMORE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO FACE YOU.
MAYBE BECAUSE I DO BETTER THAN
THEY DID AND THEY DON'T WANT
HAVE TO FIGHT FOR THEIR BELIEFS.
WE MUST ALL AGREE, OR THE
COCKTAIL PARTY SUCKS.
WHAT A CHICKEN [BLEEP] WAY TO GO
THROUGH LIFE.
THE "L.A. TIMES" IGNORED US
BECAUSE THEY ARE COWARDS WHICH
IS LAMER THAN THE LATE-NIGHT
JOSES DROOL OVER.
WE DON'T NEED THEM BUT OUR DOOR
IS ALWAYS OPEN UNLIKE THEIR
MINDS.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE'S THE ONLY FOX HOST TO POSE
ON THE BOOK COVER BESIDES
STUART VARNEY.
HOST OF KENNEDY ON FOX BUSINESS,
KENNEDY.
HE WAS THE SECOND-BEST HOST OF
OF REDEYE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TOM SHILLUE.
TAKE THE STATE OF NEW JERSEY,
AND HILARITY, AND MIX IT WITH A
BOWL OF GRAVEL.
YOU GET ACTOR AND COMEDIAN JIM
FLORENTINE.
AND FINALLY, BOTH SHE AND
CALIFORNIA EXPECT A LOT OF
BLACKOUTS THIS SUMMER.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
WE HAVE, DARE I SAY, A PANEL
FULL OF COMEDIANS.
VERY FUNNY PEOPLE WHO PROBABLY
HAVE VERY VALUABLE INSIGHTS ON
THIS TOPIC INCLUDING PERHAPS
YOU, TOM.
>> IT'S GREAT.
I LOVE THIS BLOCK.
WE GOT THE RUNDOWN OF THE SHOW
IN EMAIL TODAY AND IT SAID A
BLOCK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW AWESOME
GREG IS.
>> Greg: MY PRODUCER SHOULD BE
MORE SUBTLE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME.
IT'S ABOUT ALL THE OPPORTUNITIES
I GIVE TO EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Tom: IT'S TRUE.
YOU ARE KILLING IT IN THE
RATINGS INCLUDE THE YOUNGER
DEMOGRAPHIC.
YOU HAVE THE YOUNGEST
DEMOGRAPHIC AND LATE-NIGHT WHICH
IS ODD BECAUSE IN THE
TELEPROMPTER YOU HAVE THE
BIGGEST MOST ELDERLY PERSON
FONT.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
I CAN'T SEE ANYTHING.
PROBABLY WON'T BE SEEING YOU
ANYMORE.
ONE QUESTION TO YOU AND THEN I
WANT TO MOVE ON TO KENNEDY
BECAUSE SHE IS FUNNIER.
DO YOU THINK IT'S THE COMEDIANS
WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
LIBERAL OR IS IT THE PEOPLE,
LIKE THE PRODUCERS AND THEIR
BOSSES?
>> Tom: ALL OF THEM
ALTOGETHER.
I USED TWO THINK IT WAS A
LIBERAL BIAS BUT IT REALLY IS A
BIAS TOWARD THE ESTABLISHMENT.
THOSE IN POWER, WHICH IS WEIRD
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T USED TO BE
THAT WAY.
I WORKED ON THE DAILY SHOW WITH
JON STEWART.
WHEN HE TOOK OVER THE SHOW 1999,
HE CAME IN AND SAID TO EVERYONE
WE ARE GOING AFTER THE POWERFUL,
WHO WAS EVER IN POWER.
HE DID THAT FOR A WHILE.
HIS SHOW WAS KILLING IT.
NOW YOU'RE KILLING IT BECAUSE
YOU ARE DOING IT.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
VERY GOOD.
I AM KILLING IT.
NO NEED TO APPLAUD.
EATING INTO MY VALUABLE TALKING
TIME EVERY TIME YOU APPLAUD.
KENNEDY, YOU WERE THIS BIG STAR
ON MTV.
HOW MANY PEOPLE -- HOW MANY
FRIENDS DID YOU LOSE?
DID YOU NOTICE A SEA CHANGE IN
THE PEOPLE AROUND YOU WHEN YOU
STARTED WORKING AT FOX?
>> Kennedy: IT WASN'T WHEN I
STARTED WORKING HERE.
IT WAS 2016.
WHEN TRUMP WAS ELECTED, THAT WAS
THE LINE IN THE SAND.
FOR PEOPLE IN THE PAST TWO HAVE
BEEN TOLERANT OF MY VIEWS WHICH
HAD BEEN LIBERTARIAN AND
CONSERVATIVE.
THAT WAS FINE FOR A WHILE.
LIKE YOU SAID.
AS LONG AS YOU WERE THE CUTE
LITTLE PET.
BUT ONCE SOMEONE CAME INTO POWER
WHO OFFENDED THE ESTABLISHMENT,
THAT WAS THE LINE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WEREN'T WILLING
TO CROSS IT IN ORDER TO BE
FRIENDS ANYMORE.
IT'S A MISERABLE FEELING.
BUT I LOOK AT THE PEOPLE LIKE
CHELSEA HANDLER,
STEPHEN COLBERT, FORMERLY FUNNY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
THEY ARE SO UNFUNNY NOW.
FEAR IS THE WORST WAY TO OPERATE
IN COMEDY.
WHEN ANDY KAUFMAN HAVE DONE?
WOULD HE HAVE EVER BEEN AFRAID
OF OFFENDING SOMEONE OR LOSING
FRIENDS?
THE JOKE WAS MORE IMPORTANT.
MAKING PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE.
I'M REALLY HAPPY THERE'S SOMEONE
MAKING SOMEONE UNCOMFORTABLE.
PLACES LIKE THE "L.A. TIMES"
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE AN
ESTABLISHMENT LEFTIST COLUMN
FOREVER BUT IT'S BORING AND IT'S
FAILING IT'S NOT WHERE MOST OF
THE COUNTRY IS RIGHT NOW.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
I MAKE EVERYONE UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Kennedy: WHEN YOU ARE
GASSY.
>> Greg: WHEN I AM GASSY.
I AM STRANGE.
I LIKE TO STARE AT PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR POLITICS
REALLY ARE.
BUT I ASSUME YOU STILL ARE -- I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE A LIBERAL BUT
YOU HAVE LIBERAL FRIENDS.
DO YOU FIND THAT COMEDIANS GIVE
A DAMN.
>> Jim: SOME OF THEM DO.
WE TRY NOT TO BRING IT UP.
YOU'VE GOT TO PEOPLE THAT JUST
WANT TO PLAY BY THE HOLLYWOOD
PLAYBOOK, THE COMICS.
WHAT A JUDD APATOW TWEET?
LET ME PUT ON A TWEET THAT IS
SIMILAR.
IN CASE JUDGE IS CASTING FOR A
MOVIE, HE'LL SEE MY TWITTER
FEED.
I'LL PUT HIM IN BECAUSE HE
THINKS LIKE ME.
THAT'S THE HOLLYWOOD PLAYBOOK.
THEN YOU HAVE OTHER PEOPLE THAT
SAY JUST TELL JOKES.
WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL?
IT'S A FINE LINE BUT WITH THE
LATE-NIGHT GUYS, IT'S MOST LIKE
THE COVID JOKES.
ALL OF THE COMICS HAVE THEM.
NOW NO ONE WANTS TO HEAR THEM
ANYMORE.
THEY ARE WAITING FOR A NEW WAVE
SO THEY CAN BRING BACK THOSE
JOKES.
THAT'S HOW THESE GUYS --
TRUMP IS IN THE NEWS AGAIN.
TONS OF MATERIAL.
THE SAME JOKES.
>> Greg: IT IS A ROTATION.
LIKE THAT CAKE DISPLAY AT THE
DINER.
IT JUST KEEPS GOING AROUND.
LIKE DOING THIS WITH MY FINGER.
ARE YOU HYPNOTIZED?
>> Jim: THEY HATE WHEN TRUMP
LAYS LOW FOR THREE WEEKS, NO
STATEMENTS.
THEN YES, HE'S BACK.
WE'VE GOT JOKES.
>> Greg: KAT, WHY ARE THEY SO
INTIMIDATED BY US?
>> Kat: HE SAID "US."
YOU SEND ME THOSE ARTICLES ABOUT
THE SHOW AND I AM LIKE, I AM NOT
IN THIS.
I AM SEARCHING FOR MY OWN NAME.
I'M NEVER IN THERE.
YOU ARE SENDING ME AN ARTICLE
ABOUT HOW GREAT YOU ARE.
THANKS.
>> Greg: YOU LOST FRIENDS, YOU
LOST CLOSE FRIENDS.
WHEN YOU KILL THEM.
>> Kat: NO, I AM NOT VIOLENT.
THE SAME THING KENNEDY WENT
THROUGH.
MY BELIEFS HAVEN'T CHANGED SINCE
I MET SOME OF THESE PEOPLE.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN LIBERTARIAN.
IT'S BEEN EXACTLY THE SAME
ADDENDA BECAME NOT OKAY.
I NEVER VOTED FOR REPUBLICAN.
NEVER VOTED FOR DEMOCRATS.
BUT IN 2016 AT 2020 IT WASN'T
OKAY THAT I WASN'T VOTING FOR A
DEMOCRAT.
THE HISTORY THAT I HAD WITH SOME
OF THESE PEOPLE, OVER A DECADE,
IT DIDN'T MATTER BECAUSE I WAS
NOW HORRIBLE PERSON.
IT WASN'T JUST AN ANGRY
CONVERSATION.
PEOPLE I WAS VERY CLOSE TO IN MY
LIFE, EVEN THOUGH I DIDN'T
CHANGE AT ALL.
THOSE PEOPLE CHANGED.
THE GUY THAT I WAS SUPPOSED TO
VOTE FOR, THINGS AREN'T GOING
GREAT.
>> Greg: WHICH GUY?
>> Kat: YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> Greg: DOES THAT HAVE TO BE
A GUY?
>> Kat: FOR WHAT?
DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Greg: YOU'RE RIGHT